always kind of throws me for a loop that
this movie starts in chinatown because
that's like the one part of the film
that doesn't look i don't know
christmassy the portrayal of asian
american relations and gremlins is
actually the key to understanding the
main message of this film but i'll get
into that later on in the video first i
want to translate these chinese
characters and see if there's anything
interesting written here for the
majority of the opening there's not but
the story that mr pelcher goes into
where he eventually buys the mogwai is
called magic and as he goes down the
stairs the characters written on the
walls meaning god and strange the word
mogwai also means evil spirit so if
you're fluent in cantonese you already
know that this shop is no ordinary shot
and billy peltzer's new pet is no
ordinary little creature look i've gotta
have him it's a present for my son for
christmas what are you talking about
your son already has an adorable dog but
like this store in chinatown the movie
itself is filled with many mysterious
secrets if you want to learn why all of
mr pelter's wiki inventions are
meaningful who this guy in the giant
portrait is or the true motivation of
this drunk guy's rants then stick around
to the end of this video
it's that time of year again december
25th this jew is going to the movies but
first i'm going to talk about a movie
and that movie is
called
final fantasy advent children just
kidding i do like that movie though it's
pretty cool my name is cz's world and
today we're doing gremlins gremlins was
directed by joe dante and released in
the summer of 1984 you already know what
gremlins is let's get into the things
you missed
[Music]
we are first introduced to the setting
of gremlins through this billboard that
says rock and ricky rialto whips out the
oldies and obviously it's a parody of
indiana jones this is one of many
examples of references to steven
spielberg who directed indiana jones and
was the executive producer on gremlins
as we're going through the town the
movie theater marquis has two titles a
boy's life and watch the skies a boy's
life was at one time a working title for
steven spielberg's e.t the
extraterrestrial and watch the skies was
at one point a working title for steven
spielberg's close encounters of the
third kind we also see one of the
gremlins utter the line phone home kaka
before cutting the phone lines in
billy's house
which is a reference to the most famous
line from e.t
[Music]
we also see an e.t toy in the department
store where the finale takes place in
billy's room there's a poster for
twilight zone in the movie which was a
sci-fi horror anthology film based on
the twilight zone tv show that featured
segments from both joe dante and steven
spielberg billy's father is an inventor
now let's say you're late for the big
meeting it's really important you're on
your way in you reach up
you forgot to shave
uh i'll ignore that but later on in the
movie on christmas eve mr peltzer uses
the phone booth at an invention
convention and steven spielberg can be
seen crossing frame with a broken foot
in some kind of powered wheelchair those
are all the stephen king those are all
the spielberg easter eggs i noticed
there are probably others so let me know
in the comments it is christmas season
in the town of kingston falls as we see
when this kid smashes a snowball in this
girl's head
holy sh that was brutal
kingston falls is definitely an homage
to bedford falls from the classic
christmas flick it's a wonderful life we
actually see mrs pelter watching that
movie when billy comes home and the part
we see is george bailey running by the
movie theater marquee much like we just
saw billy doing in gremlins there are a
ton of other similarities both main
characters work at a bank both have
human antagonists who are money-hungry
holiday grouches who control the town
through their real estate practices
we're trying to have dory's pub declared
a landmark mrs deagle's trying to take
his lease away at one point we see one
of the financially insolvent citizens
bargaining with the guy that runs the
bank another parallel to it's a
wonderful life and just the look and
feel of these two towns are very similar
in a way that i can't really put into
words also in mrs diegel's house there's
this huge portrait by the stairs of
edward arnold who is known for working
with frank capra the director of it's a
wonderful life edward was at one point
considered for playing the role of
potter what makes gremlin so cool though
is that it's not just a christmas movie
it's not just a horror movie but it's
also got elements of science fiction
some of which you may have noticed
everyone knows that there's three rules
when it comes to the magwei no bright
lights don't get them wet and don't feed
them after midnight it's never really
explained what time it's okay to feed
them again or if they follow daylight
savings time but whatever when you feed
them too late they begin their
metamorphosis into grimelands it starts
when they go into their cocoons which
are awfully reminiscent of the eggs in
the alien movies in the spot where the
cocoons form there's an issue of the
famous horror magazine phangoria on the
ground so we know this is where the
horror is about to begin the movie is
literally filled with sci-fi horror
references the first example is way back
at the beginning of the movie while
billy is rushing to work
hey dr morrow
we later see dr morrow's office he's a
veterinarian which is really funny
because this is a reference to h.g wells
1896 novel the island of dr moreau which
is a story about a mad scientist who
creates human animal hybrids there is a
moment where billy's mom is fighting off
gremlins and she realizes something is
moving in one of the christmas stockings
she cuts it open to reveal it was only
this robot toy i don't really know what
this is doing here i mean their only son
is at least out of high school now like
he has a job at the bank i don't really
know who this toy is for remember that
convention scene where we spotted steven
spielberg well there are a couple more
details to talk about in that shot
actually quite a few more including
another cameo that may surprise you
[Music]
please direct your attention to the man
on the right this is jerry goldsmith the
composer of the score of gremlins but
what i really want to point out is this
guy robbie the robot robbie initially
comes from the 1956 sci-fi classic
forbidden planet in the background
there's another hgl's reference we can
see the time machine from his 1895 novel
the time machine the look of this
machine is based on the 1960 movie
adaptation to be totally honest i only
know what this looks like because of
that one episode of futurama with the
ford's time machine whose design is
based off of that 1960 movie when we cut
away to a different scene and then come
back to the convention the time machine
is now gone with only a puff of smoke
left in its way so i guess it's
operational it's a fun little background
detail other sci-fi references include a
poster for the dystopian movie the road
warrior next to billy's tv maybe a clue
that gizmo would be getting behind the
wheel before long then there are a bunch
of nods to 1950s sci-fi comics and
movies and i think there may be a reason
that they focus on this era so much we
see comics like horrific and house of
terror the latter of which requires 3d
glasses which were popular during that
time period billy watches the movie
invasion of the body snatchers from 1956
another film that features alien pods
similar to the cocoons in which the
mogwai become gremlins after pete calls
into rock and ricky's radio show to
report the outbreak of gremlins ricky
broadcast his frustrations with all the
calls from kingston falls rockin ricky's
getting fed up with all this horse and
welsh crap so cool he's referring to the
famous radio production of war of the
world that was put on by orson welles in
1938 this production was so believable
that radio listeners actually thought
there was an alien invasion going on war
of the worlds was turned into a movie in
1953. so what is the deal with all of
these 1950s and 60s science fiction
references there are a lot of them this
i think plays into the overall meaning
of the movie gremlins the period of time
following the 1945 test detonation of
the first nuclear weapon is referred to
as the atomic age this blast not only
had a lasting effect on the area where
it was detonated in new mexico but there
was also a cultural residual radiation
and a new wave of science fiction
properties flooded the zeitgeist most
notably godzilla but also the titles
that i pointed out in this video if you
need more proof that joe dante was
specifically referencing the atomic era
i noticed a lot billy has a poster for
agar's atomic pest control in his room i
don't know exactly what this is but it
seems like in the movie the gremlins are
considered the metaphorical atomic pass
we even see mrs pelter using flea and
ticular spray to exterminate some of the
gremlins later on the nuclear bomb that
the united states set off to begin the
atomic age was named the gadget a slang
term for gadget is gizmo which happens
to be the name of our poster boy for
this movie also mr pelter is an inventor
who makes all kinds of wacky gadgets
we'll get into that the second rule is
to never get the mogwai wet when exposed
to water they multiply and the same rule
applies after they've metamorphosed into
gremlins we see the leader of the
gremlins stripe jump into a swimming
pool at the ymca and this causes some
kind of a reaction causing the water to
bubble and turn green giving it the
appearance of radioactive material also
known as atomic waste the gremlins take
over dory's pub and they get a little
wild and make a huge mess of the place
when the dory's logo gets knocked over
it looks like a radiation hazard symbol
i know people are just gonna say that
i'm just looking too much into this but
we do see this a couple of times in
different places then there's the first
rule of the mogwai they hate bright
lights on more than one occasion we see
the gremlin's biggest weakness is a
bright flash maybe like the bright flash
that occurs when an atomic bomb goes off
there's even a part where mrs pelter
puts one of the gremlins in the
microwave and starts it a microwave
transfers heat using electromagnetic
radiation much larger scale example of
something that uses radiation to
transfer energy is an atomic bomb the
thing that the united states dropped on
japan during world war ii like hiroshima
and nagasaki this gremlin explodes
food's ready if you're familiar at all
with 20th century history you probably
already know why these nuclear weapons
were developed it was because of growing
international tensions in world war ii
and that brings me back to the original
lore of what a gremlin actually is a
gremlin is an imaginary mischievous
sprite regarded as responsible for an
unexplained problem or fault usually a
mechanical or electronic one the term
originated as slaying in the royal air
force to denote a mischievous creature
that sabotaged world war ii aircrafts
dante even kind of confirms that the
gremlins in his movie are in fact an
allegory for world war ii gremlins by
including a moment in the pub scene
where one of the gremlins shoots a gun
at kate and misses instead hitting a
photo of what appears to be a world war
ii aircraft throughout the movie it's
not just war machines that get taken
over by gremlins it's all machinery the
first example is billy's car which won't
start when he needs to get to work
goddamn fine cause he always frees up
billy's next-door neighbor mr futterman
spends the entire movie on a tirade
against foreign machinery one evening he
got drunk because he found foreign
machine parts in his snow plow how'd you
like to bring your plow for a tune
tune-up and find it loaded with farm
parts the movie seems to have a theme
about fear of over-reliance on
foreign-made products particularly
products made in asian countries like
china and japan the 1980s when the movie
takes place were really the years that
china emerged as a manufacturing
powerhouse and more and more technology
and machinery started to be made there
according to st louis fed this led to a
fear in the united states that china
would surpass the west's technological
dominance you got to watch out for the
foreigners because they plant gremlins
in their machinery
that's the same gremlins brought down
our planes in the big one
that's right
world war ii interestingly this isn't
the only time that we hear a character
use the phrase the big one i bet every
kid in america would like to have one of
these they might even replace the dog as
the family pit
the pelts are pit
this could really be the big one in this
instance the pets serve as metaphors for
the rise of chinese tech the peltzer
family already has a perfectly good dog
barney i'm not the best at identifying
dog breeds but if i had to guess there's
some terrier in there and maybe some
golden retriever and these are both
english breeds we see barney get jealous
that he now has competition from this
chinese creature and when the mogwai
multiply they terrorize him and string
him up in christmas lights when gizmo
first joins the family everybody loves
him but as he multiplies and takes over
it becomes a big problem mr peltzer an
american inventor has not mastered his
own products yet but he's already trying
to figure out how to make money by
selling chinese gizmos
what your society
has done with
all of nature's gifts you are not ready
the only one who seems to understand the
danger of an economy relying on foreign
products is mr futterman the same guy
who has a richard nixon campaign poster
hanging in his house a decade after
nixon's resignation as president of the
united states
[Music]
we seek friendly relations with all
nations any nation can be our friend
without being any other nation's enemy i
have taken this action because of my
profound conviction that all nations
will gain from a reduction of tensions
and a better relationship between the
united states and the people's republic
of china richard nixon's relations with
china are well recognized as one of the
most meaningful parts of his presidency
now i'm no more an expert on politics
than i am on dog breeds but from what i
understand nixon was instrumental in
opening up more trade between the us and
china in his book seize the moment he
wrote if we want to have an impact on
the changes occurring in china we should
not pull the plug on trade his goal was
for american companies to have a
presence in china but what actually
happened was american companies began
producing goods in chinese factories to
save money but perhaps mr futterman
initially supported nixon because of his
intention to take advantage of free
trade with china but now he's grown
tired of seeing made in china all over
everything he buys
[Music]
united is still shipping him over here
they put them in the cars they put them
in the tv they put them in the stereos
and the radios just stick in your ears
and put them on your watches they got
little teeny gremlins
as billy walks kate home that evening
she even hints that the only reason for
his rage against foreign products may be
related to the relocation of jobs
overseas he's been like that ever since
he lost his job
he's like a lot of people around here it
seems like a lot of citizens are
blissfully unaware of the problem like
the deputy at the police station when
billy comes to warn him that gremlins
have taken over the town he's playing
with this little cowboy game called the
western man and he doesn't believe the
story about gremlins being a threat this
could represent the typical american
stereotype that many americans believe
that they're the center of the world and
aren't concerned with international
headlines he sees gizmo get tangled up
in an american flag and totally doesn't
read the situation correctly
patriotic little fellaini
waving a flag and everything i don't
know about you but to me gizmo does not
look happy holding the american flag
when given the chance the mogwai
gravitate towards asian products like a
japanese video game or motor company the
gremlins also mess with electronics
throughout their takeover of the town by
cutting phone lines manipulating
stoplights messing with antennae jacking
a snowplow screwing with the controls of
a chairlift
cutting a police cruiser's brake line
blowing fuses all over the place and
broadcasting themselves like it's
youtube 2006. finally the fate of the
gremlins also plays into this metaphor
before the mogwai turn into gremlins and
become the main antagonist we're faced
with another antagonist the grouchy
miser misses deagle she has something
against billy's dog and publicly
expresses her desire to put him down
i'll put him in my spin dryer on high
heat so yeah she can die billy can be
seen after that blowing off some steam
by drawing a caricature of her as a
dragon being slain by a sword this
establishes the idea that dragons
represent evil but that's not the first
dragon we see there's also one in the
shop where rand first purchases an
interesting choice of words where he
first obtains the mogwai you got
yourself a bad case of dragon breath
bad breath so that's a couple examples
of dragons being portrayed negatively
well when the mogwai turn into gremlins
which happens if they eat after midnight
perhaps giving themselves that dragon
breath they develop scales and look very
reptilian much like a dragon for those
reasons it's only appropriate that billy
fights one of them off using the sword
hanging on the wall by his front door
it's just like his drawing however the
majority of the gremlins end up in the
movie theater with all the ranting from
mr futterman about gremlins getting into
the machinery and causing biplanes to
crash during world war ii it is only
fitting that the americans get back at
them with a big explosion
if you want to see me cover gremlins 2
let me know in the comments this is the
last video of this year but they're
going to be plenty more next year
remember to subscribe to cz's world for
new horrors every week ring that jolly
death bell and select all notifications
otherwise you're getting coal in your
stocking and also you'll die and i'll
see you next year assuming we both
survive
[Music]